hey folks welcome back to the Dark Horse
podcast live stream
144th episode q a that was all
technically true
um here we are
here we are uh was I do you think I was
going to call you out on things not bad
if I had said it was the 144th q a that
wouldn't be true it's the episode 144 q
a that's right that's right
that is right
um all right let's just just just launch
into this Jump Right In yeah Jump Right
In okay we have um every week we invite
the people on our Discord server to vote
on a question they would most like us to
answer uh this week's question reminds
me very much of the question that they
had us answer two weeks ago and I I feel
like we kind of got into the answer to
this but I'm going to I'm going to
remind us of what we answered two weeks
ago and then read this week's question
okay
so two weeks ago
the question from the Discord server was
what standard do you use to classify a
species as invasive if the goal is to
maintain the status quo of an ecosystem
in all places on Earth isn't that the
death of evolution
and this one this week we are asked why
is an invasive species considered to
have a negative effect on an ecosystem
what is the difference if a plant Spore
rides a piece of Driftwood and takes up
our new ecosystem or it rides a cargo
ship
yeah
all right
um
let's put it this way
there is nothing absolutely law-like
about this it is an average effect
question but the average effect is so
decidedly negative
that it leaves a little depth so let me
give you an example a counter example to
the principle that an invasive species
is inherently bad
you can have so there's a principle
Island biogeography that says that the
diversity of species on an island is
predictable based on two parameters one
of them is the distance from the
mainland and the other is the size of
the island tiny Islands maintain small
populations which are prone to go
extinct and distant islands are unlikely
to collect Mainland species
what that means is that islands are
often depoporate
from the point of view of diversity and
let's say okay here's a good example the
island where Heather did her
dissertation research is a little island
called nosy mangabi nosy means Island in
malagasi
so the mangabi island big blue Big Blue
Island despite that it was neither big
it was blue it was not big and it wasn't
blue but it wasn't Island yes although
that's one out of three Dutch pirate
maps from the 17th century if memory
serves uh show it as being a peninsula
attached to the mainland so at some
point it was not an island either right
now the reason I raise it is that it
lacked the II which is a tremendously
endangered lemurid
I think it's not technically a lemur but
it's in the same word it's a limeroid
and it was introduced to the island to
protect it now the reason that it's so
endangered
is that there is mythology about the
hazard posed to a population if an eye
is encountered which results in IIs
being killed and there's nothing else
their fatties about taboos
in various of the malagazi tribes about
seeing them and leaving them
unperturbed and so many of the places
they've become as a result very very shy
but also uh there are not that many of
them yep and actually
um the shyness is interesting it makes
it hard to study how common they are
because they disproportionately resist
being counted yes for good reason yeah
because historically once counted then
killed
so
the little Island
is used now as an II Reserve there are
no people living on it natively
and therefore the species that is
jeopardized on the mainland can be
introduced to the island there's no
downside to it because the island
habitat is a basically a distillate of
the Mainland diversity that is just down
a few there's no reason that IIs
shouldn't be on the island they just
don't happen to me and so there are
other
um Lemur species on the island
their other actually true Lemur species
on the island there's Brown lemurs
there's rough lemurs uh there are Crown
lemurs no there are no Crown levers
underneath
um there's definitely roughed and brown
mouse lemurs and there's Mouse oh
there's yeah yeah yeah there's
microcephus microcephus yeah no no no no
no no no microcephus is a is a seat no
it's microcephus boy
seems like a very stress that's the
wrong and some someone named that badly
yes I'm gonna go ahead and say that
someone named it like I was an African
monkey okay so there are there are
actually a number of lemur and lemurish
species but the III being a very
distinct very unusual looking uh
lemuroid uh also feels a very distinct
Niche it effectively fills the
Woodpecker niche in a land that has no
woodpeckers and so it's not competing
with the other lemurs for fruits or for
flying insects particularly it's
basically it's got an elongate middle
finger in it tap tap tap tap Taps
looking for
um for rotting wood and and it also has
these sort of big bat ears and also
listens and when it finds a place that
appears to be um Rife was
um crawling insects inside uh it'll dig
in and and it pulls them out and so it's
not it's not directly competing with its
other close relatives that already the
pre-existed it on the island yep but
anyway the point is
um when you have the situation of a
habitat that can support a creature who
doesn't happen to be there but would be
at home there
Invasion means something very different
on the other hand we take Hawaii
has unique
flora and fauna
that my argument in my dissertation was
that
it's biota is terrifically well adapted
to dispersal because the nature of the
Hawaiian archipelago is that it's so
remote that only things that are
terrifically good at dispersal could get
there and trade-offs being what they are
things that are terrifically good
dispersal are much less good at
competition and therefore
it is a very invasable habitat and what
happens when
a creature invades a habitat
um like Hawaii is that it drives out
native species and those species don't
exist anywhere else for the most part so
the point is diversity drops we lose
species that exist when invasions happen
to some place like Hawaii but this this
actually is a great example because it
gets right to the particular way that
the question this week was framed which
is why does a Spore for instance a seed
or a Spore uh riding a piece of
Driftwood to a new land
um less of a problem for instance than
one riding a cargo ship and if you have
ridden Driftwood you have been exposed
all of the elements to the salt water to
to the everything of the journey
and you are therefore selected to be
very good at dispersing and not very
good at competing and so you're you are
less likely to take over a land with the
kind of vigorousness as someone who
effectively yes had to deal with a time
span in a habitat that is presumably not
conducive to growth and reproduction but
the hold of a cargo ship has at least
the potential to be much more amenable
to life than riding a piece of Driftwood
and so you can get something arriving
via cargo ship that isn't necessarily
all that great at dispersal and
therefore has not yet necessarily
endured the costs the trade-offs of
dispersal versus competition and so it
may be much more likely to be able to
take off in its new environment because
it got there effectively by cheating
yeah now this is not well understood
ecologically but I believe what you just
said is exactly correct and so really
the question is
is the new arrival
disproportionately advantaged in
competition and therefore going to drive
diversity down when the answer to that
is no then there you know I think
frankly lots of islands could be used to
preserve species that are in fact
endangered by invasives on the mainland
and it isn't done as far as I know I
mean the III being a rare exception to
that so there are cases in which it
could be good but on average given the
average case of invasion it is
distinctly negative and the reason that
it is unambiguously negative is that it
reduces the total number of species
available on Earth by taking something
like eucalyptus
and driving out the native Andean tree
species that the eucalyptus competes
with and basically the point if you
didn't add any new species you just took
species that existed in Australia and
increased their range but they weren't
threatened to begin with for the most
part and you decreased the highly
unusual tree Flora of the Andes so the
Earth got poorer in diversity yeah
that's why it increases homogeneity at
the global scale and so you know if what
we want if what we're okay with
is a world dominated by a few species of
mammals a few species of birds a few
species of plants Etc then
we can stand back and let our our
introductions via means such that the
organisms themselves are allowed to
effectively cheat to get there to take
over but if we are not actually
interested in homogeneity as an endpoint
but we're interested in heterogeneity
and biodiversity and and recognize that
actually we don't know all of what
intact diverse regionally distinct
ecosystems bring to the planet then we
should do what we can to stop species
that are doing just fine over here where
they evolved from taking over in places
where they've done it yeah and that's
another really good point is the ease
with which something can be introduced
and the near impossibility of
eliminating it once it has thrived there
you know there are cases like a large
mammal uh can be eliminated you know it
can be hunted out intentionally
um but from the point of view of a plant
species that is self-seeding and
Superior in competitive capacity it's
almost impossible to get rid of these
things yeah
um so the point is even if you couldn't
spell out what the harm was
um the point is this is a one-way ticket
yeah right no and that's I mean this
again this this gets back to a lot of
our recurring themes
the fact that we don't know what all the
benefits of intact diverse full of local
things ecosystems are does not mean that
there aren't benefits and the costs
therefore are not entirely known but one
of the costs for sure is once done it
can't be undone once once they're gone
they don't come back and so
uh we we absolutely owe it to ourselves
our those who will come after us and
plan it on which we are completely
dependent to not destroy things because
we can't come up with a good reason that
the what the native things are doing
there is actually of some use that that
speaks of a hubris of an arrogance again
that you know humans are are are
typically engaging in and which we think
that we currently know everything there
is to know we are like God we can see
everything we know all of the value of
the things that have been evolving here
for billions of years and therefore we
are going to make a choice either
through action or in some cases just
laziness to let it disappear oops are
bad
there is no argument that that should be
tolerated yeah and I would also just I
would finish my part by saying
this is an invisible crisis because most
people look out at a set of plants and
they can't distinguish what's an
invasive and what isn't and so yeah it's
much more missed than it is observed
to the extent that you become aware of
what exists natively in a habitat and
what has invaded
the tragedy of for example eucalyptus
spreading around California and South
America
um is it would be very difficult to
overestimate it it's really it's a
transformation of these habitats that
have made the world much more generic
and much less interesting
um yeah and I mean in in the town that
we just left right you know and we've
talked about this before and I think we
talked about it when we were answering
the the first introduced species
question
English ivy which does fine has
competitors that can keep it in check
that cause it not to create a
monoculture of its own in its native
habitat in England
has run has just brought havoc on the
forests in and around Portland and you
know it's elsewhere as well you know we
had a little bit of English ivy problem
in Olympia but nothing compared to to
what's true in Portland and the the
forest that we lived in the little patch
of forest that we were lucky enough to
live in in Portland was encrusted it
took down trees and if it can take down
trees which it did uh and you know I was
I was out there every week and and Brett
and the boys were out there a fair bit
as well but just you know clearing it
out clearing it out clearing out it's
fast growing and it takes over and it's
very hard to get rid of and you know you
just start by snipping it out around the
base of the tree so that at least it can
stop profiting by by using the trees
that have already climbed to climb to
the light itself but the understory of
the forest where the ivy had not yet
been removed was full of ivy and the
understory of the forest where the ivy
had been removed was full of Sword Ferns
and licorice Ferns and huckleberries of
two types and salmon berries and salal
and Oregon grape and Vine Maples and
madrone not so much madrone where we
were but you know Alders and you know
more on and on and on and on that's just
off the top of my head what are like the
obvious really common understory species
that just get wiped and so of course the
understory species that are not that
common are even more likely to get wiped
because you take out one individual and
it's more likely that you know next year
the pollinator doesn't find two
individuals with which to make a seed
yeah and harder to quantify but also the
decrease in animal diversity as a result
of the invasive plants you know the the
sieving Northwest habitats that are
invaded by ivy
are not great places to watch at least
terrestrial wildlife and you're as
likely to see rats you know Norway rats
another introduced species yeah so the
basic point is there's a cascading set
of effects that just make the habitat
that much more uh
generic and empty yep
all right
first question from
darkhorsemmissions.com this week
is and I just hit refresh and now it's
taking its time really yeah so let's
just play that off so that's just
there's no questions here at the moment
well there are no answers there either
though yeah I shouldn't hit refresh I
should have just read one and then hit
refresh then hit refresh that was Santa
again
I don't know what you're seeing but but
there we go oh I'm not logged in but
I'll answer one and then I'll log back
in
um
California just made human composting
lawful
Next Step Soylent Green much oh Soylent
Green question mark much love to you too
now they gotta tell us what version of
human composting they're talking about
yeah I don't know I had not heard these
stories
the composting of humans
and the use of human waste in compost
which is presumably well given that it
says next steps sorry that green I would
suggest it's the former it's the former
but let me just do a quick search while
you discuss the
vagaries so what I would say is look
actually
if done properly
these you know we are biological
creatures we rot like any other
um yep it's after after your death you
can be composted it can be composted you
know if it's done properly I don't see
any reason uh
for concern I could see how it could be
not done properly but
um
you know I I guess probably the biggest
consideration
is philosophical right does this you
know as with cremation does it do
something to our sense of uh
who we are that matters
um
but from a biological level there's just
nothing special other than the fact that
probably because
well my hypothesis would be because of
the danger of cannibalism
uh human cadavers
um
stink specially in order to prevent
experimenting with them
um
so
you know that's what makes us special as
a decaying creature but nothing else
does yeah so
um
nothing else that I know of yeah nor can
I think of any reason that there should
be anything else special
um
you know insofar as understanding it as
a potential step towards Soylent Green
in which
um
human flesh was was itself transformed
directly into food
and here we have human flesh being
transformed into soil uh uh addendums
that is a better word amendments
amendments yes soil amendments which are
then presumably grown into food
um I can see that as a potential step
towards
the
terrible thing that would be a certainly
green-like future but I guess I can also
see cremation and the ways that cremated
remains are often disposed of as a step
towards human composting yeah I mean the
first of all I've never seen Soylent
Green
but it doesn't make any sense as a
strategy for anything
right the amount I think it's been a
long time
um and I think it wasn't all that I have
seen it but it's been a long time I
think I saw it in middle school I guess
part of the Middle School curriculum as
a as a cautionary tale I believe
um and I think it was
um
naive
but I think the idea was there's just
there's just
too many people in too little space and
here's a at least partial solution to
two of the problems yeah but it's not
that's my point is the amount of food
resource that a person represents
compared to the amount of food that a
person consumes is so trivial
that I just don't understand exactly
you know it's an error term at best
um
so it's grotesque it's philosophically
awful but it's not biologically
meaningful
um
and
composting I mean you know
part of I mean part of what we're doing
wrong is that and in fact if we can go
back to what Madagascar reveals about
the rest of the world
in Madagascar there was a tradition
amongst uh the indigenous malagazi
of varying people
temporarily in uh body boxes and then
digging them up five years later some
number of years later depended on which
of the tribes it was and
uh effectively talking to the the now
bones of the ancestor about what had
transpired in between and before
re-wrapping the bones and fresh shrouds
I'm putting them in your body so you
know unearthing them every now and again
now I think it's a very good argument to
be made about why this is actually a
very humanizing and important lineage
process that in fact actually nosy
mangabay which doesn't have a record of
permanent human habitation on it does
have a cemetery in one of the calves and
so it was a place where uh where people
from what is now monsetra at the nearest
town in the mainland would go for their
annual turning of the bone ceremony so
not everyone not all the ancestors were
disinterred every year but there were
annual turning of the bone stairways and
I in fact was invited to one of them
and it was quite quite a Marvel yeah but
keeping the
memory of ancestors alive as if the
ancestor remains present actually
lengthens The View that people have of
their relationships and things like that
so anyway there's a lot positive about
it but but the point is
malagazy people although Madagascar is
extremely poor have of course modernized
along with the rest of the world at a
bit of a disadvantage economically but
the point is malagazy people are now
distributed across the island of
Madagascar and farther
and the ceremony in which they are
buried in the first place is often
therefore delayed because people have to
get home right it's not just a town
phenomenon and so uh the um you know
formaldehyde is used to preserve the
bodies to get them through the funeral
and then I don't know that this is so I
don't I've never heard of that being an
issue among those among those people at
least absolutely at least among the bets
of masotica in Northeast Madagascar
among those who are still partaking in
these ancient ways you're forgetting
you're forgetting what we learned which
was that there were instances of people
having been preserved buried they did
not rot and then there was a question
about how to remove this now preserved
flesh from these bones to get the
process to continue so that apparently
does happen
um and yeah in any case
my point was going to be
we are naturally recycled by the natural
process of burial even if you are buried
somewhere and it's 5 000 years before
you're fully reintegrated into the
environment there is some process that
does that naturally what we moderns are
doing to the Dead
is breaking that process right
preserving bodies so that they make it
to a funeral but preserving them in a
way so that a hundred years later they
have not returned to equilibrium with
um the soil around them is us being very
short-sighted and so I guess my point is
I
formally composting people is a little
weird but it is a version of the natural
process that happens anyway and so I
don't you know I don't really find
anything especially disturbing about it
yeah and I think
um
there has been a movement among uh
among some people for a while now
to do burials without additional
chemicals in wooden boxes and untreated
wooden boxes so that while it would be a
slow process it is expected to be a
process wherein you return to becoming
the nutrients of the soil in which you
were laid to rest yep and uh you know
apparently what little I learned in my
quick Google searches this did get past
Newsome signed it but it's not going to
go into effect until 2027 so it has
plenty of time for people to continue
discussing and considering what it might
mean now there is one other Nuance to
this story
I hope I have this correct
um Bill Hamilton was one of the true
greats in the field of evolutionary
biology who died unfortunately
he had got he was a bit Reckless and he
had gone to Africa actually looking into
the relationship between polio vaccines
and AIDS
and
um
he The Story Goes that he caught malaria
um and basically died from complications
made it back to Great Britain yeah but
barely yeah in a coma and
uh anyway he died but he um he was a a
tropical biologist who had a favorite
forest and he also had a a uh a a wish
that when he died
his body was to be staked out in his
favorite forest and the forest was to do
to him what it does to dead mammals and
basically he was to be distributed into
this Forest by you know beetles and ants
and all the other creatures that do that
kind of work
um and I think it could not be arranged
I think the fact is it did not happen
because the legal obstacles to getting
it to happen were too many yeah I think
that's right so we now own all three of
the volumes of
narrow roads of Gene land in which I
assume that that final wish that letter
in which he has his final wish is
printed uh but
uh I'm just trying to see if I could
come up it's a beautiful it's
beautifully crafted paragraph or so in
which he describes what will take place
yeah uh and I was at a near tropical
forest or a Paleo tropical forest yeah
um
but I'm not I'm not finding it um at the
point that all those books the point
that our bookcase has come in and all of
our books are unpacked we will find
those books and we'll maybe we'll come
back to that someday your bookcase will
come in I hope so
all right
trans activism has begun so okay
trans activism has begun to erase women
pedo activism will soon erase trans
people
I predict that in the coming decades
trans species zoophilia and cyberphilia
will erase that
you know activism will soon erase trans
people
I don't quite get it
this is from this is from someone who
writes questions weekly
um so I'm I'm sure that there's
something something real there but I
don't I don't see I don't see it well
okay let's uh step into a different
realm okay
there comes a point at which
you know each generation has its music
and the avant-garde music doesn't sound
like music to the elders but it's very
compelling because it breaks certain
rules and they're thereby discovers new
territory and then there comes a point
at which you realize oh
the mechanism by which music progresses
is the breaking of rules that were once
held sacred
let's just break all the rules
and then it sucks then you get just
noise right
um or you know same thing happens in
painting and you get white on white
which is
very beautiful in the same way that a
white wall is very beautiful
which is to say not at all but in in its
defense and I don't believe I've seen
white on white but certainly heard about
it I do believe that and I know this is
going to sound stupid to most people but
I do believe it was different shades of
white
maybe so I think I have seen it
um
SEC wants to know what some famous look
I'm trying to tell you something about
the general process General processes at
some point it occurs to you that all the
rules are going to be broken and you
fast forward and you do it and you kind
of wreck the magic right likewise 37.5
seconds of Silence right
um
so that was a good one yeah it was a
good one it's not long enough but
I think it's exactly the right length
anyway
um
I think
the point is
this question recognizes a pattern by
which you know trans activism does
traffic in exactly the idea that well
it was scandalous to be gay and then we
all came to understand that it wasn't
scandalous
and so trans is the new thing in that
Niche to the degree that it's pushing
boundaries of what's morally acceptable
yes well and I mean and that but I don't
but trans isn't replacing women because
women weren't morally acceptable right
like I would I would have said them
transplacing
um gay people and you know now
Pito whatever is gonna replace like I I
just don't that's not my point my point
is but I think it might have been the
the point here my point is the idea that
certain things are beyond our
comprehension and therefore they will
all be normalized
this is nonsense there are certain
things that must never be normalized
um you know uh pedophilia pedophilia
being very top of that list yep right
and so to the extent that these people
are going to go white on white on this
and just say look there is no morality
um everything is normal blah blah blah
then these are the
enemies of
of all that we have accomplished and so
anyway they are
they are wrong they are pushing
boundaries that must never be pushed and
um
so yeah we'll leave where it leads and
eventually it will either lead to our
destruction or it will lead to us waking
up to what the hell have we participated
in yeah and us on doing it yep
love you all do you have any opinions on
the copper IUD as birth control
um
I
it's been a while since I thought about
it I did think about it but it's been a
while
I think all birth control
um messes with some system that you've
got to be you got to understand what
what you're messing with except for you
know timing or or
really barrier methods
um and you know copper is doing
something
chemically
that apparently can cause you know one
of the effects is it can cause very
heavy
cramping for for women with the copper
IUD and so anything that's gonna in some
subset of the people who have it cause
reliable bad symptoms I do wonder what
that is what what else is going on then
uh that said copper is
understood to be relatively inert
um it is an element it is in our diets
I think if if you don't aren't one of
the people with a very bad reaction it
is likely to be a better option than
much of what is out there but I would
want to look more carefully into it
before saying that with any more
confidence than that
yeah I'd say you know this raises a
whole different point which is we modern
folks feel entitled to interrupt
uh the process of
producing new humans
we we feel entitled to break the
relationship between sex and
reproduction and
uh while I don't want to live in a world
where that isn't under some kind of
human control I think you know people's
sexual impulses just simply producing
lots more humans is a recipe for
disaster I think also
you know rape provides the obvious proof
that we have to have uh controls because
you can't put in the hands of a rapist
the ability to generate Offspring at
will
but anyway the point is
it is not surprising that every method
has negative consequences the question
is what's least negative
um and
uh I don't know I don't claim to be an
expert on copper IUD or anything else
but the point is at some level realize
that we are
um
availing ourselves of Technologies to
disrupt a process as fundamental to what
we are as any process and that it's not
surprising that it's hard to interrupt
it in a low-cost way yep it's not
surprising
among certain academics and political
Elites is a view that human populations
should be reduced how much do you think
this plays a role in things like
pandemic control where yes they really
do want to see people killed
um I don't know I don't think I don't
think we do know yeah but I will say I I
don't even think
I think it's too generous
to imagine that this there are uh Elites
whose position is human population
is too high
um I think there's a strong argument
that human population is too high with
mechanisms of consumption that are as
destructive as ours so I don't think
that that's a non-argument I think it's
a real argument but I think there's
another argument that's much more
Central here
which is that people who are
disproportionately powerful which often
generally means wealthy but people who
are disproportionately wealthy and
Powerful look around at the rest of us
and they see riffraff who are degrading
their playground
and they've fantasize I think about us
not being here and them having all that
much more of the glory of the world to
themselves and what role that plays in
how seriously they take
misery and Misfortune of humans I
suspect they are far more uh indifferent
than they would be if they didn't
secretly think
um wouldn't this all be great if the
people I don't care about uh were gone
yeah no and that and
you know people aren't wrong
to uh
suspect that in some of the rooms uh
filled with Elites where they think that
everyone sounds like them and feels like
them
uh
the Riff raffer understood to be a
problem
if you worry that that is what some
rooms sound like you're not wrong
and it's demoralizing and horrifying
once you've
ever been anywhere near those rooms and
you realize oh my God this is how some
people sound
and they're fine with it
well you know this is in part the
underpinning of the
you know in our book where we talk about
the various different kinds of Frontiers
we talked about three different kinds of
Frontiers that exist and we argue that
there's a fourth that we have to find
um but the third front Frontier is a
transfer of resource Frontier and the
idea comes from the recognition in fact
I remember
the day I learned it
uh very good high school teacher whose
name I have forgotten
um who pointed out that the black plague
had created excellent times in Europe
it's something the black plague were
excellent times but it was The
Disappearance of a large number of
people who were consuming resources they
were effectively up against carrying
capacity and
the reduction in the number of people
meant that the wealth that the number of
people had access to uh so that was true
even this this teacher argued that was
true even in an era when labor was
really required to pull nutrients from
the land yep like I I that that
surprises me given that that was before
most of the labor-saving devices of
modernity existed and you know in order
to get in order to farm you need a lot
of people who were willing to do the
hard work of farming right but it's also
true that you know you disappear large
or substantial fraction of the
population and the number of people you
have to feed goes down immediately and
the you know metals that already had
been surfaced for example Remains the
Same so anyway yeah if some of the
problem was okay we do you know we are
metalsmiths and we do have shovels and
plows and such but we don't have enough
of them then that would potentially
solve that problem yeah but nonetheless
I think that this under lies
the impulse for example to demonize and
then genocide
people that the whole idea is
um
producing real growth is difficult it's
a very haphazard process you can't
guarantee your ability to generate
growth through Innovation but you can
figure out who you can Target get rid of
them and then you can take their stuff
and that takes an awful lot like growth
canned it does
um so it's that process that we have to
stop because with the power at our
disposal not only does that create human
tragedies but it creates an existential
threat to our ability to continue
um so anyway it's
it's a it's a very dark viewpoint but
once you see it it it requires
um that we address it soberly so that we
don't end up targeted by Elites who view
us as uh you know
uh I don't know what's the Nazi term for
pointless consumers or something like
that
um but anyway something like that
question
I'm a new data science masters of
science student at University of
Helsinki but I'm a Washington Native I
want to do a comprehensive stratified
risk benefit analysis of covet vaccines
for my thesis
can it be done given the data
Boy again I don't know
I don't I don't know what all is
available
I know that whatever is available you
have to be you know even if there are
sufficient
data sets available to you to do the
kind of analysis you want to do you of
course have to be suspect that of their
source and how true they are
I would say two things are true you can
absolutely do the analysis
it will be rendered
noisy by the distortions in the data
that were introduced there
for reasons of profit and who knows what
else I think that's not I mean that's
systematic bias though that's not noise
uh yeah I agree it is systematic bias
um
but the point well
you don't the problem is it is noise
because you don't know
um
if the point is risk stratification
based on age you do not know how it
differentially impacts the uh
recording of
harms between ages in other words you
could have a system
that given the particular question he
might be addressing with a particular
data set that may have may have had bias
introduced in a particular direction
his question may result in a noisier
analysis
um simply because of the particulars of
of the way that the question has been
framed yeah or if I can put it
differently if if what happened was they
systematically under counted Adverse
Events but they did not do so
differentially by age then the point is
it may be noise rather than uh
systematic bias well in this analysis if
if that if you knew enough to know that
then you could say whatever result I get
is conservative is going to be
conservative relative to the truth
because I because I have established
that there was systematic under counting
and I've established the systematic
undercounting was across the board it
was either randomly or at least
haphazardly
distributed across all the you know
across age say and I'm looking at age
and therefore if I find a pattern I can
assume that the pattern is actually
stronger than what I found but that's a
lot of knowing about what's in the data
and I don't think he's going to know
he's just going to be able to know what
how was it the data how were the data
collected you know by whom under what
circumstances what are they claiming now
how much of it actually got to him but
the fact is we have a lot of information
on Adverse Events
we have a lot of information from the
Veris system from the yellow card system
from the military system
and so I think with time the picture is
getting clearer yeah but knowing a lot
knowing
that there have been a lot of Adverse
Events from the various systems that do
exist
is
good but it's different from saying I
want to do a comprehensive stratified
risk benefit analysis of code vaccines
for my thesis the yellow card system
Vera system don't allow that
they allow you to say oh oh okay yeah
there have been some problems but they
don't allow what he is specifically
saying he wants to do no I I disagree
with this
you're talking about a thesis level
project
and so it is completely within the realm
of such a thesis to analyze and figure
out how to weight the various different
which data to analyze how to weight the
different uh evidence to come up with
our best estimate given a very polluted
data set but I know
it just take theirs yeah all we have is
here are people who had reported mostly
by health care workers that they had an
adverse event we don't know what the
population that that was pulled from is
so you can't you know if you don't know
the population that was pulled from you
can't do a stratified risk benefit
analysis of code vaccines all you can
know is okay you know now I can see
because there are some demographic
characteristics associated with each
Fair's entry I think you can say oh you
know compared to say the US population
we see that you know young males are
more likely to show my architis Paradise
for instance but you can't say compared
to the vaccinated population because we
don't have that associated with theirs
well first of all I don't believe that
there is no mechanism for estimating
these things I don't think any mechanism
is going to be
um
precise
but I think the point is this is what a
thesis like this is about right
in the you know analysis of the
Holocaust you are faced with the fact
that a huge fraction of the evidence of
what happened is actually filtered
through the Nazis
um who fully intended to hide the entire
episode
so
this is what a thesis should be able to
do how good is a question of you know
the quality of the evidence to begin
with and the quality of the researcher
and their ability to sort out I read
this and I start from the data do exist
every single person who got vaccinated
had some record kept of them getting
vaccinated they exist as a human being
they have an age they have a sex they
have a location they have comorbidities
you know they have underlying conditions
and you know all of that exists so these
data do exist that's what you want and
then you want to tag that to you know
Adverse Events yes or no but I don't
believe that it is going to be
accessible to to Matthew here the data
that clearly do exist because everyone
who's been vaccinated knows that their
data were taken down and they now have
it on a card somewhere and like it's
it's known by it was known by someone at
some point but was that collected and if
it were imagined to be shared and this
is this is the things that I think I
think it must have been given the kinds
of research is beginning to come out now
that some people are claiming to like go
in and look at like oh what we have is
um you know more reticence for boosters
among the this population among people
aged this much so that must mean that
those data associated with every single
person getting vaccinated exists
somewhere but I don't trust that the
people who are managing overseeing
sharing those data are actually
inherently bound to Scientific Integrity
yeah I don't either on the other hand
you know I don't know what the various
tools at his disposal might be but
developing a questionnaire that you
distributed to Citizens that bypassed
whatever reporting mechanism there were
that you know sought to figure out
were you were you not vaccinated did you
or did you not have an event whether
there was not that's obviously a
possibility that's not data science
right like that's you know and I'm just
like I'm looking at within the confines
of this question like that's something
an Anthropologist of socio sociologist
might do or public health uh person but
that's not what a data scientist does
well but I'm not first of all I I I'm
not going to pretend that I know but it
seems to me that a data scientist might
well say okay here's a systematically
distorted data set we know it is that
how do you correct it well one way you
might correct it is you might devise a
questionnaire that allowed you to
estimate the level of bias and then
apply a filter to your data exactly yeah
now I I think that has the potential to
um to correct some systematic bias in in
such data sets I don't know of that
being a tool it is used by data
scientists but that would be interesting
if it were yeah I don't either but given
if data scientists can be stymied by
pharma's systematic bias uh on the
relevant data set then seems to me like
data scientists need to Avail themselves
of a calibrating mechanism like that yep
okay next question when did we start
Zach how long have you been going uh
fifty five zero okay
the real Anthony fauci book by RFK Jr
has left me with a bleak view of the
state of the world how do we move
forward and can trust be restored are
you positive thank you both much love
and not are you positive the answer that
the person asked the question hasn't
heard but are you are you do you have a
positive outlook
all right
um let me start
I am simultaneously
first of all I was truly even though I
have spent literally decades thinking
about capture and the hazard that it
poses to us
I was thrown by the real Anthony fauci
that book and frankly I don't know
anybody who spent serious time with it
who wasn't
right I think even
Robert Kennedy was thrown by writing it
um I know that Pierre Corey was thrown
by it even though he's been living the
horror story up close and personal right
in any case my point is
there's a difference between knowing how
dangerous this stuff is and how it works
in an abstract way and seeing how it has
unfolded with actual lives on the line
the especially the section of the book
that deals with the
um prequel to covid which is HIV
right that you have the same players in
many cases you have the same Playbook
right and you can see the same uh
consequences strategies and tactics
right it's it's a jarring presentation
right and to the extent
that we have spot checked it there's
maybe one or two places that
it might not be as cautious as it might
be but overwhelmingly it is extremely
well documented and stands up to
fact-checking real fact checking yeah
um
that said I do find that in one way I'm
more hopeful than I've been even though
I think things are far worse than
they've been right kovid was a
absolutely catastrophic failure of so
many essential elements of our system
that that
uh is reason for fear but
more people are awake than ever before
the number of people who have figured
out that something about the system was
lying to them that it was indifferent to
their potential death
um to their suffering to the loss of
loved ones that I think we have a better
chance now of having the conversation
that we five years ago couldn't have had
right what do you do now that your
journalistic system and your academic
system and your medical system have all
failed you at this level right what do
you do what do you do with the fact that
we don't have we have isolated
journalists and we have no
um means we have no high powered
journalistic Publications which can be
trusted
so
um
I don't think you're wrong about the
level of horror and the fact that it
might cause you to feel hopeless but the
other thing is we gotta hit bottom right
and to the extent that people can
convince themselves that their system
still functions they won't be motivated
to change it to the extent that they
know that their health was actually
jeopardized by A system that lied
through its teeth about what it knew
there is hope that they will change it
and I would say that is a piece of good
news that we haven't seen uh I don't
think in my lifetime people have been in
the dark and they are less so now they
are sadder but wiser
yeah I saw something
some pole out of Canada suggests the
unvaccinated were
angrier
than the vaccinator he wasn't angry it
was like angsty or less satisfying
like [ __ ] well no of course we are
uh the the unvaccinated are more likely
to be the ones who are actually have
been awake for longer and are saying oh
my God it continues it continues I I
agree but I also have to say the lack
the fact of not having to worry every
time your heart rate goes up over what
did I allow myself to be injected with
um does makes me less angsty than I
would be I'm quite certain yeah but
that's that's the wrong matched pair is
you're comparing yourself to how you
would be feeling you would be feeling
with what you know if you were
vaccinated not the population some of
whom chose to do it and so that's who
chose not to
um this is a suggestion possible t-shirt
suggestion Heather we are living in a
despotic clown World Brett it's even
worse than that
yeah all right yeah
uh Brett do you have thoughts about
making tax voluntary to remove incentive
for corruption
um voluntary text will not work
uh
remove incentive I mean that's that's it
yeah no your Center taxes we need better
politicians and better taxes
we need a less Baroque system so I um
who was the guy Steve uh
in the world
Forbes
ran for president briefly on the
platform of a flat tax in which you
would file your taxes on a postcard
and I made the point at the time
that file your taxes on a postcard
is a good idea that a lot of
skullduggery hides in the complexity but
there is no reason that that tax has to
be flat right it could be Progressive
and simple
um and so anyway what I would say is the
complex tax code is obviously a weapon
of War
um
as you and I talked about on the podcast
a couple weeks ago
we are not against
um paying taxes even
high taxes if they are well used to make
a civilization that works really well
but boy does it suck to pay high taxes
that are basically used to persecute you
um to persecute you and do not super
high tax rate in for instance Portland
Oregon where the services are not really
happening anymore felt more like theft
than taxation yeah where they had
decriminalized crime for example yes
where the tagline for the city is the
city where it works yeah
um yeah yeah w-o-r-x no doubt
um
but anyway
yeah I don't see it look any
a voluntary tax exists it goes by the
term charity
right the problem with Charity or
philosophy if you've got a lot of money
right and the problem with it as I tried
to explain in my TED Talk a million
years ago on the personal responsibility
Vortex is that a voluntary tax
punishes the benevolent and rewards the
ruthless and therefore a system based on
such things evolves towards ruthlessness
right it doesn't mean that
charitableness is a bad characteristic
it's obviously a good one but a system
that is based on you know the good
people cleaning up the mess of the bad
people
is a system that gets worse over time
and that's what we've got It's A system
that can't abide anonymity right like
things like tithing which is Charity
works because enforcement is possible
because everyone knows who you are and
can see what you're doing and so a
massive system like the U.S population
where anonymity is everywhere it won't
work yep and I think your point about
philanthropy is a good one we have a
voluntary tax system right if you're
wealthy enough avoiding taxes is
something you can do because the number
of tools at your disposal is large and
the point is you can then choose to fund
things as you would that's a voluntary
tax right and the point is how good is
that system now you know it it's
terrible right what you want is a fair
tax in which you get good value for the
money that you put into your society and
we don't have that by far not yep
with the lipid nanoparticles attracting
to like and the lipid lining of female
eggs what do you think the jab is doing
to a woman's eggs and ovaries
I mean I think with uh you know with the
research that may or may not have been
in any way compelling that we talked
about that was reported on wapa this
week
um you know as it seems to have
confirmed what was
widespreadly understood to have been
taking place
for many women there were immediate
effects and
hopefully for almost all of them it
really was temporary and uh and those
lipid nanoparticles Decay over time and
disappear and
no harm no foul
I wouldn't bet a lot on that yeah I
would say though I think we get
uh lulled into a kind of
self-sabotage on this a it's not just
what women were reporting about their
Cycles which was a very consistent
message it's also this admittedly it was
one study in which the distribution in
mice showed uh accumulation in ovaries
and
what I would say is
a
be very careful about over interpreting
the evidence based on named symptoms
okay myocarditis is
a symptom that we see because of the
nature of the heart presumably the
damage of myocarditis is happening all
over the body but we don't even
necessarily have names for the
subclinical presentation when it's
happening in your liver or it's
happening in your brain well or or and
or it's happening in tissues with repair
capacity and therefore what you will see
the prediction is as I'm sure you've
made elsewhere or here many times before
the prediction therefore is that you
will see an effect on lifespan yes but
there will be shortened lifespans among
those who were exposed maximally to
these ingredients yeah I think the
proper interpretation of this based on
what we know is
uh this is damaging to every tissue the
heart is a special tissue which is why
we are focused on the symptoms of heart
damage
um but that basically yes accelerated
aging is the prediction accelerating
Aging in every tissue and lipids are a
feature of every tissue
um
so there's that but the thing that I
think we don't say
is
everything
speak for myself everything I know about
the
pharmacokinetics and the Damage that's
being done here if I just feed that all
into a mental model
um what it says is
any exposure is bad but the damage is
cumulative the you know if you got one
shot don't get two right that's the
thing is you have a lot of control over
how much damage and probably
most of the people who got one with the
liquid nanoparticles
paid some price but not a major one
um
but the point is for God's sake stop
listening to them when they say safe and
effective because they obviously don't
mean either of those things yep
okay
um we're not going to get through all
these questions let's do two more let's
do them quickly even though they're big
ones
um
I'm gonna answer before I ask this first
question I don't yet have a take so the
question is what's your take on the
Nordstrom bombing love you guys
uh this being
um
what happened
in the Baltic where seismologists are
now saying yeah it wasn't earthquakes or
landslides it was it was explosions
pipelines
um being blown up
this is affiliated with the the leak
that has been thoroughly documented
I think I think the answer is I'm not
well enough versed in this I've been
explosions rattled the Baltic Sea before
unusual leaks were discovered on the
Nordstrom one and two pipelines running
underwater that doesn't sound like well
I don't I don't know what you're talking
about now so I think that's what I'm
talking about
um I don't know enough about it to have
a take I just don't either but I wanted
to
I didn't want to appear to be ignoring
it because we were afraid of it or
something I just don't think we know
enough yet I would say maybe someone
does but I don't um
leaks are bad uh
sabotage is possible I I don't know
beyond the obvious I don't know
what is the most intriguing unanswered
question in biology
that's from horse Burger
I don't have an answer to this one
either
uh I often don't have an answer to
questions like this what's the best
what's your favorite
um
um I bet you I do have an answer but
it's gonna take me a little while
searching the uh the back back burners
so I should have instead of clicking
done on that I wish I knew how to go
back in
here I can yeah yep yep yep yep yep yep
so I'm gonna I'm gonna see about
forwarding that to next week and seeing
if we have
yeah I've got a bunch of candidates
where I think I've got the answer so
that seems like cheating
and then I've got one in which I really
have nothing
but you want to you want to do it or not
well the one is
um
how did how did The evolutionary process
start how did Life Begin that's a
genuinely difficult question
you and I have talked in our book and
elsewhere about the fact that natural
selection is an extension of selection
that adaptation is an extension of
selection where you add heredity but the
question is where did heredity come from
in the first place and that's genuinely
difficult
um
so you know
it'd be cool to know the answer to that
one I'm not compelled that we ever will
um
is speciation adaptive I firmly believe
that it is
but I don't think we yet have a picture
of why
um
why the biota looks the way it does
because we've misunderstood speciation
to be a byproduct of adaptation rather
than an Adaptive process in and of
itself so that's on the list
but I bet you there's something else
though yeah I feel like there's probably
something big although the way it's
framed you know there's there are Aryans
that I would really like to know a lot
more about uh but it's not a question
per se so you know there's like research
areas like
um like how you know given given though
what we've got as our unit of heredity
as our as our
is our ingredient of heredity is DNA and
RNA the packing and unpacking of it
which you know has experience there is a
lot more that we know about that than we
did in the 90s when it was no one was
interested in this at all but I think
there's still a ton hiding there that we
don't know very much yeah and actually
that might be related and this and this
sorry in this the epigenetics when
people for a while I think still but
people love to say well that's
epigenetics like you know epigenetics
actually is going to be part of the
unpacking and packing stuff like how how
is it that you can have so few so few
genes in say you know 100 no now we
think it's like twenty thousand yeah
like twenty thousand in a human
um that does all of this uh it's going
to be about when they're exposed to
they're next to how they get packed and
therefore are affecting the you know the
translation of their new neighbor as
opposed to their old neighbor uh there's
just there's a lot of intrigue there
yeah and actually so I would say
the problem is it isn't a question
but the
I'm increasingly intolerant of the idea
that Explorer modes are controversial
right how could they not exist and the
point really is
what is the diversity of Explorer modes
how do they facilitate the evolution of
adaptive States
and uh
epigenetic regulation of genes is going
to be fundamental in that story yes
right so that's that's really the thing
is there's a there's a a missing layer
of adaptive of Darwinism and the
question really is what is the content
of that missing layer and how does it
explain all of the things that we find
ourselves
um groping for plausible sounding
answers like you know
how is it that mutations change the form
of a creature right
yeah
all right I think we're there we and our
sleepy cats yes
anything else you want to say before we
sign off here
no I mean I think we're there
all right well we'll be back next week
and until then be good to the ones you
love eat good food and get outside it's
worse than you thought but it's not
worse than I thought
[Music]
foreign
[Music]